!
>> UH-HUH.
>> KENNY, MY QUESTION IS --
BASKETBALL STANDPOINT, IF YOU
START LOU WILLIAMS, WHAT IS DO
YOU GET OFF THE BENCH?
>> DUNN HAS TO COME IN.
>> WHO?
>> KRIS DUNN HAS PLAYED 11
MINUTES, LIKE BOBBY PORTER, THIS
IS YOUR MOMENT.
GUARDING WITH THE BULLS,
STARTING AT TIMES, BEEN IN
GAMES.
GOT TO SEE IF HE CAN PLAY.
>> I WOULDN'T DO THAT.
I WOULD START JEFF TEAGUE.
I WOULD START HIM.
>> HE'S NOT ON THE ATLANTA
HAWKS.
>> WHO IS?
>> BIG DUMMY.
>> I'M SORRY.
TALKING ABOUT TEAGUE.
>> I'M FORGETTING SOMEBODY.
I CAN MAKE A MISTAKE.
WHO IS ANOTHER GUARD ON THE
HAWKS?
>> KENNY SMITH.
SERIOUSLY.
>> WE'VE RUN OUT --
>> BRANDON GOODWIN FILLED IN
BEFORE, BUT HE'S ALSO HURT.
>> I HAD WRONG GUY BUT WOULDN'T
START LOU WILLIAMS.
>> START KRIS DUNN TO BE IN
NATURAL ROLE?
>> NEED SCORING OFF THE BENCH.
DUNN HASN'T PLAYED BUT 11
MINUTES, BUT LOU WILLIAMS IS
COMFORTABLE OFF THE BENCH.
>> BUT THERE'S NO WAY YOU CAN
SWING A TRADE FOR JEFF TEAGUE.
>> I UNDERSTAND THAT.
YOU GOT TO GET SOME POINTS OFF
THE BENCH.
LOU WILLIAMS IS GUY WHO IS GOING
TO GET HIS POINTS.
THEY NEED GUY TO GET THE B